ich schaue dich nicht mehr an ganz
unscheinbar schicken ja den schicken hat
jetzt wieder mehr ganz unscheinbar
zugriff basketball
service meine lieben es kids und
herzlich willkommen zur allerersten
platzierungsrunde sozusagen der neuen
serie rote top ten mit der weisen heute
rockel und spielen vielleicht teil und
mich ein bisschen unterstützt sind hier
beim parken in dieser runde war ich muss
mich echt konzerten
ich habe das ja das chamäleon kid noch
nie gespielt außer heute also ich sags
heute zum ersten mal und machte
direktzusagen letzten let's play dann
schauen wir mal wie es gelingt mir kraft
gibt seine kraft letztlich ein wenig
kraft ins freie
das weiß man nicht
ich habe auch keine ahnung aber sicher
ist dass ich mich jetzt hier mal
präsentieren muss wir schauen in die
steps platz 94 95 ist erreicht wir
direkt mal so ein schweinchen verwandeln
ein ich glaube nicht die kann man schwer
kämpfen hätten
verliert nicht
ich finde keine ton komplett
unscheinbares schwein was ihr einfach so
durch die gegend geht und sich ändern
mutet kommt niemand auf das dass wir das
ist vielleicht chamäleon gut sein
könnten wenn ein alter scheiße scheiße
ich muss mal jetzt dringend behält es
allerdings doch alt ist ja auch richtig
scheiße bewegt allerdings müssen jetzt
dringend mal dringend regen mal holz
holen und wenn man den alten trick an
den trecker rechtsklick der rechtsweg
spam der aufnahme oder kommt es für die
lecks des todes es kann jetzt nicht
gebrauchen so wir sind immer noch ein
schwein können so schnell schuhe machen
und allegorie um ich weiß auch dass nico
knab knapp knapper
oder ist glaube ich auch dass auch das
tauchen kann mir jetzt gehen wir mit yes
karelien chamäleon ach was das ist ja
geil ich habe karten chamäleon gekillt
das als schafe sozialen verkleidet waren
wir jetzt selber schaaf ist ja und hab
auch schon voller rüstung fünf
pluspunkte das läuft wir sind ein schaf
und greifen an
achtung achtung bitte bitte kommt kommt
auch schlecht nein aus hatte der
resolute snaps war richtig knapp
jetzt aber kommt für mich hatte olala
jojoy wissen ein schaf junge [ __ ] uns
ja jetzt jetzt so ein alter das war ja
mit joystick alter richtig geil rief das
ja das passiert mit sex hörte sogar ein
scharfes schwert halte ich habe einfach
einen stack pfeile hatte ich geh mal
dieses schicken hier jetzt bin ich kein
ding für mich kein ding für mich zum
wasser rennen ist der 4
hör ich habe von chicken gekippt mit dem
bogen ich noch mal verwandelt der würde
des menschen jetzt schicken chicken
chicken zugriff zugriff zugriff opels
auf tief ist auf die behaupten ein mann
ich bin da habe ich bin dem kindle
gehört das war echt wert wie viel zeit
haben wir schon 4 minuten
wir machen einfach eine neue runde und
setzt in kurzen kann wir sind gleich
wieder so da sind wir wieder
runde nummer 2 die erste hat ihr diesen
schönen bilder
deswegen wollte ich dir drin lassen aber
danach ziemlich gefragt wobei ich sagen
muss diesen delfin der superb war den
hätten wir uns auf jeden fall respekt
und ich will es nicht menschen komplett
versuchen muss kann ich eigentlich nicht
mal abgesehen ist es vollkommen unnötig
ist man am anfang ihres komplexen hat
dann rechts ist eine kiste kommen die
hunde also eigentlich schon mal safe
kommen jetzt da wir sind ein chicken
diamanten dann hast du dir busplatinen
wir manchmal postplatz ich war schon
ziemlich heftig
hinter ihr eine kiste ist so geil wie
ein huhn einfach ist ein scheiß baum ab
all das würde ich so gerne sehen du
musst hier unbedingt danach mit einem
store aufnehmen ich würde gern eine
perspektive sehen nichts sagen da steht
ja ja ja ja ja komm ich bin nicht
dagegen nicht mehr an
ich schaue ich nicht mehr an ganz
unscheinbar schicken schicken hat jetzt
spekuliert mehr ganz unscheinbar zugriff
basketball egal ist jetzt müssen sie
sauber verwandeln
dazu brauchen wir einen bogen das ist
auch sehr gut kann man viel machen ich
spiele gern bogen der arbeits nur kein
food aber das fühlt aber kein problem
wir müssen uns dringend neue verwandeln
oder weil wir einfach mal egal mach
jetzt juli solo modus juni modus und hat
nein jetzt gerade kennen
ich habe immer noch kein schwert du hast
es wieder redet ihr den tastaturen
gespielt modus das mega mega laute
tastatur irgendwie ich bin kein tier
warte auch jetzt so und wir haben auch
schöne nahrung gefunden zumindest meine
baic potato das ist jetzt nicht das
gelbe vom ei haye kommen egal
wissenschaft.de wir sind einfach nur
scharf ja es ist voll geil ich hätte nie
gedacht dass man leute wirklich tun kann
damit aber es funktioniert ja manche
gags aber auch relativ schnell ja klar
ich meine teilweise ist auch
offensichtlich gerade eine weile gezockt
hat auch fakten kenne kein tier
du musst nur gut schmecken du musst halt
wissen war das ein schaf hatte ja okay
jetzt gewartet wenn man diesen schritt
im fall macht dann geht das so metro
group 24 kommt man hier
hier ist ein kleines schaf jetzt will
ich gern lern ich will das unbedingt
sehen
bitte nehmt neben einer fröhlich kunst
auch kurztrips und ich will das
unbedingt sehen hab ich nehme mal auf ok
und jetzt kollege war
wenn bogen schießt dann wirst du gar
nicht verwandelt ich weiß es richtig
geil ich lasse nicht wissen back ist
oder beabsichtigt auf jeden fall wird
man lieber schnell zum ruhm verwandelt
hatte lag bei dem bild jung ich bin noch
ein hühnchen was willst du denn so ich
bin dass mörder hähnchen einfach geil
das ist richtig geiles vom liga-alltag
nur noch vier leute wir können diese
hunde eigentlich locker easy gewinnens
bisschen anstrengen was will ich jetzt
nicht so etwas großes wie eine kuh ja
das nochmal schicken
ja man alles klar mörder hähnchen auch
das ausschaut als mörder hähnchen ist im
anmarsch
ach übrigens leute schreibt unbedingt
wieder euro wunsch geht es für die
nächsten folgen in die kommentare
ich habe jetzt schon gelesen bombe war
ganz beliebten vampir habe ich mal
gelesen angler hey so vielleicht
schreibt es nochmal in die kommentare
damit wieder ein bisschen klares
meinungsbild bekommen weil aus den
letzten kommentaren der letzten konnte
ich einfach nur herauslesen dass wohl
hier
dieses kit also familie und euer
lieblings für diese folge
wir sind immer noch ein schicken was
hier so durch die durch die wälder
pirsch man kann sich leider immer 5
modus nicht selbst als schicken sehen
das war voll cool dass wir wissen aber
echt ein richtiges magic man denkt so
bauhaus klein und unscheinbar switch und
dann kommt einfach kommt das kicken an
und hält einfach alles
ich glaube schon 56 kills dieser runde
dass ich hab mich mitgezählt
aber genau das genau sein als auch
gedacht genau daran wir machen so
schnell an die erschwert ist einfach
nicht mehr dem boden wachsen
umso besser und so nur so guter um so
guter junge ja ich habe es heute erst
richtig gesagt gut guthaben gutes jahr
ist so alt wie ihr sehen könnt leute
minecraft hat gerade neue linie bekommen
die sind sehr vielfältig und sehr wendig
und vor allem sehr aggressiv und die
platten ins damit ihren flügeln neben
dem ob ihr leben so bp ist in münchen
münchen versuchte er eine lagerhalle
gebaut
kitty matyas anlauf alle gebaut guck mal
hier im team t-mobile egal was passiert
mit leuten die fallen alles klar ist
aber nicht so gut ausgerüstet ich werd
ich wette dass funktion im finale auch
der track ich wette mit euch und trick
ist ich sag schon zweck alter trick
schon so geil eigentlich der mann muss
funktionen ich muss mich noch verwandeln
ist nicht weit davon ist auf jeden fall
der ruhe aber kuzin halt nicht so an und
erreichte unter
elfmal kommt da jetzt nach den bäumen
denn hat er mich gesehen ja irgendwie
ist einfach ganz normale kühe kollege o
a ist ja der ist nicht gut in kürze op
alte täter in eine andere richtung der
wsop cryptic ja aber jetzt ist eben
nicht zurückwippt plätze nach unten
sie sind kängurus um auf den baum
gefunden er ist um auf den baum
gesprungen haben wir nicht das ist jetzt
echt spannende texte
jetzt sind wir wieder die kurve auf den
baum geschmückt wurde natürlich leicht
aufmerksamkeit erregen
dabei sucht dich ja gegeben weil der
mensch kassierte typ so eingespannt dass
richtig spannend der überschuss wird
immer wieder verzögert es nicht
oder ist es richtig und alter der
richtige schritt
hier ist ja das alter der war so übt auf
ganz geschafft geil jungs vibro heute
erstmal durchatmen
wenn euch die folge gefallen hat lasst
den daumen nach oben
tipp die beiden jungs in der
beschreibung und ich würde sagen das
projekt macht richtig viel spaß
ich freue mich auf die nächste folge und
ich hoffe wir sind wieder haut rein
macht's gut und schön